okay today's episode we'll get to in
just a second we have a beautiful guest
in and this man has been through it all
you know he's had the highs and lows of
a career and not the lows but when you
have highs you have the alternate the
alternate side of those you know he's
had the peaks and valleys will say that
and he's he's a special guy and I'm
happy to be in here talking about him
and talking with him and this episode
today is brought to you by pranks
anonymous and look we all know people
that need to be pranked okay let's be
honest about that sometimes people look
like oh I don't know anybody that needs
a prank you're lying and you are lying
now there's a fast easy affordable way
to send anonymous pranks in the mail
remember the mail dude it's still alive
and that's by using pranks anonymous
dot-com that pranks anonymous you'll
find a prank for anyone and everyone you
think is not a prank for somebody that's
crazy
anybody Native Americans you know people
that are people that have been tortured
anybody friends family you want to cover
somebody with glitter well they got that
hitter they got the largest selection of
glitter bomb pranks they even have the
world's biggest glitter bomb the mega
glitter bomb you know what I'm saying
it's four times the size of any other
spring-loaded glitter bomb this is a
real site check it out go to pranks
anonymous dot-com use the promo code
Theo for 10% off you can do a tall man
change somebody's day get edged you ever
seen somebody trying to get glitter out
of their scalp that's a month-long
adventure baby you know what I'm saying
that's just gay lice living up in your
dome baby come on man you can start that
for somebody praying synonomous calm bro
you're right under Maron dude I'm
looking at the charts holy [ __ ] Congrats
on I know you're recording right now
sorry
4:05 bra like box lawson clothes this is
I don't know [ __ ] helicopter on the
freeway or some [ __ ]
Wow it's a [ __ ] parking lot dude I
left before Google told man but dude I
think people would listen to you Jamie I
really do I would listen to you and you
there's something uterus a kind of this
fascinating creature you know yeah
you're like a loch ness monster but
you're not hidden it's like your pumps
are out Jamie Kennedy's here with me
today and I'm super excited man yeah
dude you've been working so hard I mean
I see you in the comedy clubs all the
time I know I've been doing it put its
let me ask you this because it's like
have you know I was like on the road
forever right and then um I did a thing
with Melissa McQueen and she's like you
gotta come to the store and do a show
and then I did and then I was like you
know talking to people Michael if you're
on the road all the time he's doing five
or six shows why do you do you know in
town because you're dead and Bobby Lee
man really hit me to it he's like dude
you gotta perform in town in front of
your peers with your peers because being
on the road is completely different yeah
and then ever since he said that about
two years ago I just been like but also
I feel comedies gods superhot and would
you say the last three years yeah in
town because I've been doing comedy for
a long time but we didn't you tell me I
mean you might even know better yet to
me it has but my breath of perspective
isn't as large as yours well stop using
big phrases that doesn't the only one
big one oh well I feel like you know in
the like you know like the last two
years I almost want to I've been hitting
the town hard yes
you know Netflix is been doing the
special
who's opening up in Amazon and everybody
I mean you know it used to be like a
special you would drive down Sunset
Boulevard and you would see you know one
person and be like you know bigger and
blacker like damn that's like yeah and
now it's like yo you see one building
you see a bench you see I mean there's
specials there's a lot of special
there's so many specials so it's like I
was like I wanna you know work on that
and try to work towards doing a new
special yeah and that's why I've been
doing it but that I have never in my
history I started in the lately
early 90s almost lady but 1990 was when
I did my first set mm-hmm I've never
seen town this hot really yeah I mean
dude you are let's see 16 comedy
superstars yeah yeah you being one of
them yeah and just like Bam Bam Bam it's
like people are so spoiled and you go on
the road and you sell 400 tickets and
you're like I'm the man and then you're
like doing 15 minutes and they're like
whew that was a tough set and then
realize cuz you're everyone you're
playing for the Yankees yeah and so I
was I'm glad to be in town doing it
because it makes me better but it's like
it isn't ten it's fine it's yeah it
definitely seems hot are we good on the
levels neck okay everybody is in it and
now I'm not because you were saying that
before like man you're hitting it hard
and now I don't want to stop because I
don't feel like I don't want to miss a
step yeah you know I mean yeah well
that's what it seemed like it just
seemed like you've been picking it up
it's like you know I mean I have to show
someone I feel like you're on most of
the time and as comedy always doing with
you your career cuz I mean when I first
got hip to you you know you were mostly
acting mm-hm and his comedy but you were
a comedian before that yeah so most
people don't know that I started as a
comic so I my heroes were you know I had
a few heroes boom Eddie Murphy number
one Mike Meyers number two Wow and and
you know that I was I was kind of really
into SNL you know that was my know so I
moved to LA it was an extra
it's a long story but then I start I
start auditioning for improv groups in
the in 1990 and I got in a couple of
improv groups and I would go to improv
groups and do like they would have these
groups at schools and we do these shows
maybe like 20 bucks a shot which is like
you know good you're making a living
right then a lot of them shut down and
there was that's why what was it like
there wasn't like crimes or anything
going on it was just like you know how
long how profitable is an impasse
if the school board isn't paying you to
do a show about it you know better
nutrition but make it funny or you know
what fire drills or whatever right yeah
nuclear warnings hurricane warnings dude
everything yeah so I I is acne so now
you couldn't even do that if you went to
schools now you know they wouldn't let
five comedians into a school no no wet
in the afternoon like one o'clock is
like they're tired and put a hat on and
like you don't know what character that
has gonna be and it's like I need a
location the Playboy Mansion
you know or whatever and everybody's a
pedophile like crazy that dude well
there's just so many pedophiles out
there now man I got I quit I got rid of
the app the stranger-danger app or
whatever what is that we can see how
many pedophiles are in your in your like
area is that a real yeah it's like
stranger danger it's called and you can
see how many pedophiles in your area
dude there's so many it's I won't even
jerk hogs I'm afraid somebody's gonna
molest my semen like there's so many
pedophiles it's baffling bro wait
where's the semen go bro I thought oh so
you're saying your semen turns into a
human no what I'm saying is there are so
many if you were to get on this app now
and see it I don't even know if we can
pull it if we can pull up a site or
something but there's stranger danger
it's where you can see how many
pedophiles registered you know people in
the Union I guess is the unionized
but registered sex offenders are who are
um within your area but dude it's it's
everybody like I think everybody so then
what I was saying I won't even
masturbate because I'm afraid somebody
will come over and just touch that you
know yeah oh I got just cuz it's so
young yeah
but see how smarty thanks for Lana man
oh I have a question yeah so did you
ever notice oh there's a I'll go back to
what we're talking about but the
teachers oh look at this
oh god that real is that real are you
kidding
that's just off a Colver Boulevard that
is brother damn all the red dots are
touches yeah that's a Shake Shack baybee
everywhere is a Shake Shack oh my god
oh say shake shake shake I really do
like have you ever seen so many hot
teachers touching I know is it a story
every couple of days am i right well
yeah what is that what is it you think
cuz something is do you think something
is going on or do you think that it's
just now it's a popular story always
been and I think the Internet has made
everything transparent and I think it's
always been happening but now everything
you can see everything was there a
teacher that ever tried anything with
you or did something cuz you were tall
you're a tall guy so you probably had
that you got an opportunity so that
height helps Oh nobody's teachers not
touching a [ __ ] short kid Adam's
apple
so I don't want to name names okay first
of all you know I used to do this joke
which is true in size on altar boy
mm-hmm I was never even touched which
made me feel like I wasn't cute yeah I
had to join the Boy Scouts but here's
the thing is that I did we did have a
teacher who was a nice guy
and he would take me and my buddies out
to Burger King like once a week
you know we get the member of those busy
handicapped nah he was normal cuz I know
a handicapped gather would do that you
would do that in the Philly area but he
that's a good observation so he would
take us out three of us and we would
just you know eat those whoppers and we
get fries and he would really let us
order yeah and then the I didn't know
anything anything was weird
until because we're from Philly so
Philly we kind of like turn the tables
on the touches we like touch the touches
yeah yeah and so he we see jawbreakers
big thing in eighth grade seven great
and beautiful candies - yeah and they
were hard to deal with but good yeah and
they look big and they would these
things would puff up your cheeks so when
we would eat him in school we would get
in trouble so in an order or not to get
in trouble we would make him eat it and
the game was how many jaw breakers could
you fit in your mouth and so we had him
put about three and three in each cheek
I mean this old guy is middle-aged nice
guys who took us to Burger King and he's
like I can fit seven and he had that
accent I wasn't no he wasn't he does I
can put eight and so but you know that
area of the world soft text is we're not
in throat and we jammed them in there to
where the point when we're putting them
in at the Burger King jawbreakers in his
mouth you know more and this stuff was
like you know charlie chip market and it
wasn't till I was probably like you know
23 and I'm sitting on my couch you know
like you know just after a Taco Bell
audition I'm like damn maybe that guy
had ill intentions but nothing happened
everybody I know more well I just said
more we jammed in his mouth hmm
happier he was beautiful so whatever
that was that was mine it told us yeah I
grew up with people like that
oh that's like a fourth world country
man the more you put in their mouths the
happier they are yeah
and I'll say this man this that reminded
me of a story of this boy I used to know
this boy named Michael um I don't
[ __ ] say his name or not but oh don't
put him on blast oh I don't think he'll
I don't even think he could hear okay
but um this boy named Michael Roach was
his last name right and uh yeah rut not
very well here's the thing so what
happened to Michael Roach was he had he
was you know kind of uh he had extra
salivary glands you know and he was he
always just leaking out of the sides of
his mouth you know he was real damp up
just up in that [ __ ] face hole you
know he was just sweating out of his
lips all the time you know like it would
be easy to get DNA off of him yeah
say yes wow I could take someone your
finger put it okay you could say he has
had it he gave it all so he was a
drooler
yeah he's a drooler guy well they had
this man his his mother used to date one
of her students he was substitute
teacher and she dated this boy that was
in her class who was 16 years old and
his name was Clint mic clip but with an
N in it yeah and so she dated him so he
would come over to the house and they
would hook up inside the substitute
teacher she's probably 30 and this boy
Clint and meanwhile me and her son
Michael Roach would sit outside and
Clint's car and Clinton had a ham radio
one of those CB radios you get on there
you know breaker breaker you know y'all
breaker breaker
how many guinea pig yeah I reckon I
reckon how many can you fit so we'd sit
out there one time we get talking to
some man on the interstate yeah he
drives off the interstate
no this is before catching predators
yeah this is way before MSNBC this
before then we're catching anybody no
this is like a lot yeah yeah got you
this man shows up and then he's got me
and Rush sitting in his truck right and
he is having us put tootsie rolls in
each other's mouths you guys are doing
that to each other yeah he's like you
guys should see who you know who could
have the most Twitter rolls in their
mouth I was like similar so this jaw
braking thing was probably happened at
the same time something okay so this is
jamming so this is happen yeah where's
that on the mask where there's stuff a
mouth that so wait so how much did you
because those things can get yeah oh
this boy could get Michael Rutte meanie
that's the thing he had to slick doors
on his face you know I'm saying so he
was hiding 14 16 17 in there but wait
the longer than many are the many 16
minutes but what how old is he what a
pervert do the love I'm saying goes yeah
well there was a better bargain you got
like one of those today half the price
in that long one I'm gonna say it got
weird so we uh so yeah no the minis and
but thank God he he he could hold so
many because at one point I got Clint
came out of the house
saw this dude and beat that man's ass
Wow I said what ended good yeah no
diddlin there no didn't know nothing
wild but yeah it was popular Monday but
if you got molested her we had a you
know a school teacher that took us to a
Marilyn Manson and dropped us off in
there were 16 you know and he was you
know he went to jail for pedophile and
then it was more popular but what's
going on now because now it's women with
boys uh what's going on well they're
living the dream these these young
students yeah I mean tell me if some
teacher hit on you when you're 60 oh are
you reporting and then if your mom catch
and says this is terrible you go mom
don't cock-block are you saying that yes
am I wrong
Bobby when i lo I bet there's so many
students who's like mom dude then not
these girls stay with me bro they're not
just sleeping with ya they're taking
them down and in the end the Priuses
mm-hmm behind the damn basketball court
yeah dude
they're not only doing that they're
running train yeah they're bringing an
intramural sport at ya doing - three -
town all aboard they're running drills
dude straight up to London bridges and
they're getting report and then they're
documented the teachers yeah are
documenting it drawing one lady had a
sketch artist come and draw pictures of
him [ __ ] how crazy is that it's not
real yeah it's like and then the
husband's will find out and the one dude
I'll never forget this girl have four
she had four and it was like two at a
time two at a time with toys three -
time for you know del taco break you
know and they're in high school so you
know they can go a couple rounds Oh and
so she went and the husband says for
easy serve in high school does the
husband say I know that she's sick and
we're gonna work through it Wow I was
just I just take a cook yeah how do you
think he was watching it no I just think
he was he liked it he was a cup yeah
okay I call it you know right now it's
all that's going on with men you know
it's good that the women are cleaning
out the creeps but you know being in a
man is a little hard in here in areas
right now like the alpha male is getting
a little bit you know it's a little oh
yeah it's risky to be an alpha male tone
off my hands yeah yes I was beta I'll
call it you know the betas are coming in
i calling the beta broom boys Oh them
soft boys yeah which one you know which
a woman really like it's like you know
they want somebody some women not all
women
I'm not saying don't get mad but you
know they want a guy that if you're if
you're a strong woman you want a guy
that you can you can take care take take
care care but those guys that send up in
the corner you know these some of these
guys what a woman is getting done yeah
why did they they would like a broom
yeah oh yeah I mean what the full
activity yeah right
and it's like I'm sorry mistress there's
not that's a known thing is it you could
google that that cavity surgeons know
I've heard about that there's a lot of
men who were searching their own
cavities with all kinds of accouterments
broomsticks and shovel handles
everything but there are yeah you don't
think they're all over sure quoi you
know you learned stuff oh yeah well I
mean I didn't learn till you could jerk
off when I was 20 and I learned you can
jerk off like that I didn't took me no
the other way dude I used to do this
thing where I would tape both my hands
together with duct tape right and have
my brother tape and I would say it was
for like school for science that's what
I tell him yeah and then I would tape
like a hole in my hands like this and I
don't know what I thought the tape was
for and then I would go master it with
both hands at the same time Wow and it
was a stupid Wow yeah and I have but
then the crazy part was yet all this
tape you know and you had like semen on
the floor wherever or something yeah and
you had this tape on your hand so then
it was like this real whodunit like this
kind of Harry Houdini you know goes to
the bunny ranch kind of [ __ ] scenario
and you're you know when somebody's
beating on the door and you've been
saying you're in there you know [ __ ] and
like I must have taken so many shits
when I was 14 years old how do we get
the [ __ ] just because he I was always
having an excuse I was in the bathroom
oh okay I mean I was in the bathroom at
my office an hour a day when I get home
from school Wow well our odd masturbates
I was weak in the legs did I remember
dude the first time ever masturbated I
climbed up a shelving unit right and
found some
pornography that pornography magazines
in a fifth of Alizee wit uh
just swamp waters just like colored
liqueur you know just a real Big Brother
separate was orange flavored or
something and I took a swig off of that
and I was jerking off from the shelves
just up on the shelves just couldn't
even get down that's how enamored I was
by masturbation and addiction addicted
to that Wow you were doing you're like I
[ __ ] just fell off the shelves after
I came I couldn't even keep myself up I
couldn't even handle myself
you were like drunk but also euphoric
yeah but that's how much it meant to me
like to go and masturbate to go have
that armor I would bike 5 miles across
town up my buddies dad at some
pornography magazines in their bathroom
yeah and I bike 5 miles to get there
just a jerk off and then bike back yeah
you know what you told me before we
started the podcast you got a lot of DMS
from those lonely man oh yeah man that's
gonna help this cause this right you
didn't have another thousand I loved
jerking off and driving five miles for a
beaver shot yeah yams blown the [ __ ] I
was trying to get bees bro you're gonna
get busy see you know 72 but how do we
get
but yeah the ladies we went on it's hot
late now and it's good all right where
we going it's hot ladies now with these
young men but yeah I think that there's
something else going on because this is
what I start to wonder is there
something else going on in the ether
yeah in the ether like men haven't been
you know women are feeling like they
that older men or to you you know that
there's they're affected too much or
that they missed out at a young age like
do you think there's any and that's why
they're going for you these young you
know these boys in their classrooms do
you think there's any of that do you
think that's crazy I'll show you this I
don't get how teachers if you're a
teacher supposed to have a level of
intelligence then you're gonna do
something that which is clearly illegal
and you know immoral not only are you
doing it but you're doing it and
documenting it and having a digital
footprint right psychotic do why do I
think they're doing it I think because
if you do that job a little bit I've
been reading about I mean there's a
story every three days yeah I think
something about you you like to be you
know center of attention look at our job
control you know maybe some of these
guys is 16 but they look 20 I don't know
the fantasy I know there's a lot of
fantasies man but I just think people
get caught up in the moment I don't know
I think some of them probably have
issues obviously it's all right no I
like that I mean the fact that they're
documenting it too that tells me
something else because if anything like
back in the day you would may be a
creepy dude would do something like that
they would hook up with young girl they
would document it that was like
something you would see on her early
season of Criminal Minds you know like
that was enough of a plot like that was
real stuff but now it's like if these
women are documenting it that shows to
me that they want to they want to keep
it for some reason that they want that
you know that treasure trove a little
artifacts they can go back and look at
but they're gonna go back for the bank
right they're going back to you know
yeah that's a spank bank maybe yeah
but the bottom line is it's crazy and
it's happening more and more but if I
was in high school and I was 16 and my
teacher was flirting with me I would
think that was a good thing but it was
illegal I think Jamie just hit it I
think these kids these guys are hearing
about these stories happening so they're
getting more emboldened and they're
trying they're they're they're making a
little pass at the teacher more than
they would I know I did his teacher a
senior Spanish teacher when I was in
freshman year and I loved her but I just
never thought was a possibility later I
found out she was messing around with a
senior I could have had a chance the
whole time but I didn't think it was a
possibility now these kids know it's
real oh no some pictures are coming hard
at the guys number one and number two
yeah what's number two okay so what
number one was what that I forgot number
one number one was that the teachers are
coming they're coming hard
yeah the teachers are coming hard now
but I agree that's a great point that
net yeah because I was just job raking
it yeah but that was you were just
hanging out with a [ __ ] free whopper
job breaking it
you know it was a big deal with me
tickling yeah
these got you like to tickle they like
to be tickled you know tickle them that
type of stuff
oh I wasn't doing anything and I wasn't
getting it yeah I know hot teachers I
had nothing I had jawbreaker that's all
I had but I could see you you know if
I'm a hot teacher I'm not going I mean I
think a tall guy would have more but
were you like tall and lanky were you
telling you were lanky yeah you know but
it's like a teacher is not [ __ ] that
dude a teacher's [ __ ] like the jacked
kind of like backup quarterback type of
dude really you know yeah no offense but
the tall lanky didn't getting [ __ ] by
the teacher like you know what I'm
saying that do mate why you know just
because you don't know what's going on
with him like one day his head's real
long or his Chin's real long or his
growth spurt
yeah those gross ports are I think I'm
scary to people around that age yeah
give me the kid and he looked you know
one day one of his arms is going longer
and the next day it's just just too much
sprouting you know like you're really
you're doing too much like one day your
friend would have a [ __ ] the longest
neck in the world you're like what da
[ __ ] Terrance we in trouble we talked
about this the world scary right now no
this is a world that we live in we can't
hope that we live here dude we didn't
even put ourselves on this planet I know
but do you ever find like because we
always would do comedy it's like I do
jokes about it man it's it's the most
intense time to do come in terms of
political correct right right that I
think it's getting better though I think
it's on the way back I okay good
pendulum swinging back I do notice that
100% I've had three different times at
three shows in town two times and then
one time in an out of town people have
approached me and asked me why I did it
Joe
oh yeah and was there always a certain
topicals of what like joking about
molestation was it joking about I do a
joke that I say you know I read my
myself on the Internet and I read
something I said
people say Jamie Kenny looks as if
Bradley Cooper Matthew McConaughey raped
Bradley Cooper hmm so it's a rape joke
so there's rape in it has the word rape
in yeah but I there's no rape happening
at the imaginary it was written about me
as a block and those would be your
parents if that did happen exactly
they're not bad looking parents yeah and
you can't make fun of your own parents
no and so they went the people when
officer why are you endorsing rape
culture I'm like I'm not it was written
me and I had a whole dissertation Wow so
I just listen man I'm not just listening
yeah well the heckler I feel like I mean
unnie did the documentary the heckler
yeah and the heckler these days is was
that what Michael Addis who was that way
Michael nice that is so Michael the
other day yeah but if that documentary I
feel like the heckler now is the media
kind of well what we did when we did
that was I was just working on in my
first hour right when I did that I was
in clubs and I would get heckles not so
much crazy heckled I was getting heckled
but it was more like drunken embolden
people and they were hilarious and my
comebacks were pretty damn good too and
we started documenting it which was
filming me to get my bits down yeah and
then end up becoming I'm like dude this
is something here and he agreed and
that's what heckler started how the
heckler was a live-action person right
so it was somebody in the audience no
matter what the event hey you suck right
then I was around Oh 5 I was 6 when it
happened and there was blogs or the
raids right and that's when people not
the New York Times or LA Times were
reviewing your movie that's when you
know this is a Waffle movie calm yeah
real sight
how many waffles 0 out of 5 waffles did
your movie yet yeah and I was getting
you know not a lot of waffles yeah two
waffle yeah I got a wobbly waffle and a
half damn and I'm like dot you Waffle
House yeah you know you know I gotta
have to write so I haven't who the [ __ ]
is this guy and then that [ __ ] started
springing up and like you know eggplant
calm eggplants and then so everybody
started having this voice and I realized
heckling wasn't just the people it's
Nate was now bloggers now it's the media
yeah but it's gotten even crazier
umbrella which is which is you're right
and you know I'm not gonna suck my own D
but the movie was a little early ahead
of its time but now there's something
what I call cannibalism hmm where I mean
artists are straight-up heckling each
other hmm
suddenly like comics you know heckling
each other or you know music people are
[ __ ] having Twitter Wars or that's
crazy to me three
104 what's crazy I guess whoa okay good
this because I this business is insanely
difficult it's so [ __ ] hard and the
fact that you're in this business means
that you're not exactly well-adjusted
so it's painted you know what I'm saying
yeah okay I didn't come here for you no
because uh you know my life is happy
right you stay here because you might
have come here with your dream but it
does start to change yeah this is
hurtful it's hurtful here and it's it's
it's in it but it's a but it's beautiful
you know those ten fifteen minutes I
have onstage or the five you know 20
seconds to say my line before they still
cut that's that's where I'm happiest I
love it you know people's reaction I
love it but it's it's we're in a
paternity a brotherhood and I feel like
people when I don't [ __ ] with anybody
because yeah I know how hard this
journey is that's my opinion and I grew
up where my heroes were like you know 50
no fifties you know sixties I understood
what Hollywood you gotta read Marlon
Brando's book and he would say that
there would be a premiere of Mann's
Chinese and it would go from Mann's
Chinese down past the Gower you know how
long that is
mm-hm that line that's like a mile for a
premiere and Hollywood was beyond beyond
special and to get in was insanely
difficult you know you had to be past
the gates now what's beautiful is all
the tools to do it yourself you can get
in but it's in it's no barrier to entry
and there's issues there that make sense
yeah I mean is you know there's couple
different topics in there I mean for one
it's like yeah it's like anybody can get
in here now for sure and I think you
almost have to create your own way in
these days behind percent I don't think
it says
you know it's um there's so much
nepotism now the business has been going
on a couple more generations you know or
another generates like it's just it's
really hard to get into this business
unless you're easier now right but
unless you create it it's hard to get
into this old business but if you create
your own way then it's easier and it
then it's your own business
you know I think like you know used to
be the big three networks and Fox you
know and and or trying to get into a
movie but now all of that business is so
like it's so cutthroat and jaded over
there if you just try and wait on these
cat casting directors or these to me to
produce her to coffee shop that shit's
not happening anymore so you have to
create your own [ __ ] so that they come
to you now yeah a hundred percent but
wait you are surprised that I said I
don't haggle all their artists why are
you surprised I wasn't surprised that
what I'm saying is that the media is the
heckler now that was my thought like now
the heckler you should be that man
sitting in the front row I can deal with
that now now the heckler is like I mean
well the comedy is kind of divided and I
feel like there's real comedians and
then there's also like joke writers who
were on stage and it and I feel like
this the industry caters a lot more
towards writers um when it's like what
do you mean I could duck could listen to
that off say people are gonna hate that
you said that but boy I could listen to
that offstage what's it what makes this
person interesting just that they got up
there and they're just writing and then
reading it on stage my is that inert is
that it's not nothing it's not
entertainment damn but I would watch a
guy like Sebastian Maniscalco to my to
my ball skin falls off my balls 100
percent
he's an energies and entertainment
entertainer daliyah
watch him entertainer yeah you go right
down Maniscalco stuff for Delia's stuff
on paper it's a that's whatever maybe
but you watch them do it and it's
electricity electric totally a great
entertainers that is a mazing note and I
think they don't have them anymore it's
like we're like half these people like
it's just like is this entertainment
even if it's not even great I'd rather
it be like Mike Epps like one of his
specials that came out like two years
ago got a bunch of bad reviews and stuff
but I thought it was at least it was
entertaining yeah you know he's not a
writer Mike Epps is a perform
well I'm the same way I feel like I'm a
performer you're a performer I'm
sometimes we'll go out there and go back
and people be like now he's big yeah
it's like he's got energy but it's like
but there's times where I'll be low
energy but it is like I agree my
performing is much stronger than my
writing but I dude you're saying some
[ __ ] gold now people probably gonna
hate that but I so agree with you and
you know what that has to do it hmm
charisma yeah charisma yeah why don't
that waddle sailor yzma is what you're
saying and it wasn't waters in the
industry waters eNOS should go after
charisma anymore it's like you could sit
in the Comedy Store for one night and
see so much [ __ ] charisma it's just
like what how everybody in this place
doesn't have some isn't you know well
there's a lot a plus right there's a lot
of successful people in there it's good
yeah but yeah it just seems sometimes
like like we've gotten away from
entertainment and they've just tried to
here's what I want to say on that point
and we're talking about Weiss I don't
talk about so I'm a hypocrite well yeah
no look we're all hypocrites man we're
just trying our best play what I do say
is this is though is that [ __ ] mean
lost my point again is that is that I do
feel this wing like you put yourself
there's something that that happens
sometimes in comedy not all the time and
maybe entertainment what people are
being cool and cool is the death of
entertainment yeah the coolest people I
know what [ __ ] real yeah and they're
not cool yeah I'm saying so I feel
sometimes what you're saying is like
when I go on stage I can bomb [ __ ] I had
some tough sets last week and but I try
to be vulnerable right and I feel that
sometimes people don't want to do that
because they don't want to seem like ooh
vote I can you know go fail but right
there's more people just saying that
they're vulnerable then it is actually
being vulnerable now like straight up
Bono
yeah and I do agree with that and that's
what there's I think Hollywood sometimes
look his vulnerability is weak yeah I
know I like my dad you saves come I'm
nice doesn't mean you know
week you know right yeah it is cuz I'm
nice doesn't mean that I'm weak yeah so
it's like I do feel like I think that I
do feel like the town feels like oh he
you know there's snark man it's a small
town you got real snarky and that's why
I think that's you know I think there's
gonna be a new Holly this is a
perception of mine I think in the next
10 12 years you're gonna have a brand
new Hollywood that's gonna form maybe 15
20 years or a separate Hollywood this
kind of performing I think you seem to
be based out of Nashville and I strongly
believe that there's a ton of artists
says there's a lot of money there tons
of people move in there and it's a place
where people get it's not as infected I
mean I think a lot of Hollywood there's
just so many ages so many writers now
it's like the sons of writers and
grandsons of writers it's just all the
same people it's like they've never even
lived anywhere outside of nepotism is
that bad I think it is well you can't if
you're not good Theo they're not gonna
laugh for acting and stuff you can no I
think you can get away that in that
industry a little bit more I think you
can yeah these days with they don't even
let you really do that much on screen
these days it's like it's all like this
cut to that cut it just seems like a lot
more that's what I feel like I feel like
you mean an explosion no it's like I
feel like a lot of times on the screen
they don't let it breathe oh for sure
yeah you're saying get to the [ __ ] and
that's how yes now it's more get to the
[ __ ] where you used to be able to kind
of you you fell in love with the
character more a little bit cuz you got
to see a little bit of them well dude
you're talking about like Chinatown
you're talking about you know Cuckoo's
Nest that should Netflix I mean they're
what movies have you seen where you're
like this isn't a dull thriller movie
yeah
when have you seen that there's not that
many dunkirk the only good movie I've
seen in about three years and and it was
good and um
well you don't like there's all the
types of movies you don't like you know
like any superhero movies oh oh I saw
Ant Man have you seen that about that
man that's an ant it's like about Paul
Reiser and he gets some heat Paul Rudd
and he gets in some issues with house
cleaning products or something and ends
up being um I don't know he ends up
getting infected is infected with ant
ism yeah
but he powerful because you know there
100,000 times our own strength
mmm which also who [ __ ] knows how
strong that it's like it's dude lose
every battle I've ever seen if I can I
know
[ __ ] you hang I don't know they're
always like they're a hundred thousand
tons our own strength who gives a [ __ ]
dude yeah I'll [ __ ] a thousand of them
up right now that's right yeah that's
right they got good PR but they have bad
there's no talent there yeah you know
great PR speaking of PR yeah I feel like
STDs have got a new publicist really
damn you drive down Santa Monica
Boulevard Melrose you see that ad for
syphilis oh yeah and that's all these
get a checklist I don't want to see that
[ __ ] I just came out of eggslut
I'm already having a [ __ ] egg sinful
that they got sores a 7:00 a.m. I'm
gonna coffee egg [ __ ] syphilis child oh
no damn gonorrhea dotnet you see this
[ __ ]
they're [ __ ] blowing ah I mean their
bag baby
whoa they're calm they're fit lead in a
[ __ ] Marvel movie do you got a riffle
us the new one is gonna riffle
oh dude gonna riffle us bro bro I mean
it burns when you piss but uh herps just
getting in on the game Oh herps is the
big way I'm waiting for crabs like but
don't for real yeah what is it why they
promoting this [ __ ] hard I don't know
man I think they don't want people
having it I saw a truck HIV truck the
other day and it's I guess it looked
like a food truck but it was also like
curing HIV I'm like dang they're doing
everything now food you know yeah it was
like HIV away or something calm HIV away
calm okay like I don't think that's
gonna cure it you know that basic
suggestion yeah but um but yeah all
right I'm gonna give Jamie a gift from
us today and this is the ridge wallet
brother oh dude so you got that hitter
now that's that front pocket carry a lot
of people been carrying their wallet in
their back pocket and those people are
slowly becoming extinct
okay it's got a little metal around
there oh that said a couple of
accoutrement you can use to tap into
that sucker bra wait is this what's just
do that does whatever you want it to do
to give it to your cousin but look at
the wallet though that's that real
hitter okay where's the money go oh you
can fly uh yeah with that you can ply
tootsie rolls out of your cousin's
[ __ ] grill I can also use this like
you know quick Stefon when I'm in New
Orleans or you can just come up in is
that money clip you put the cash on the
side you put your cards in there and you
carry it in the front of your pocket and
you got that little hitter okay you
could change somebody the fabric of
somebody's life you could remodel
somebody's whole a ortus I thought that
was a different hitter but okay let's do
it oh you could do that okay yeah well
you can chop it up to of everybody you
guys watch you know we just listening
very mellow we're watching endless this
is like government-issue steal that
steal brother yeah and I stopped a
bullet dude to tanning right so you put
that there but then you got this where
you can also change your glasses yeah
you watch anything vegetables anything
you do you could do a remodel a small
auto you could do whatever you want and
that special alloy metal from space a
space metal why so few other people that
own these Buzz Aldrin I'm taking it
yeah Space Jam anybody was that that was
in Space Jam so you got one that's from
Ridge wallet Ridge wallet calm slash
Theo get 10% off that beautiful hitter
and look I took me five days to love
mine and I love mine now use it every
day
I think I'm loving mine after now you're
gonna love it dude get rid of that rear
carry and get that front pocket carry
thank you and it still smelled like food
I'm like I can't even
I'm giving blood in this thing or
whatever you know it smells like [ __ ]
chicken sausage back here and I'm so
[ __ ] or we shed in pints back here
yeah they shouldn't let some vehicles go
from one thing to another thing you know
there should be they should just the
government should have a better hold on
that yeah damn so but yeah ma'am it's
getting wild out there and if I could go
back in time
dude I'll be straight up I know I was
something for my own town I listened to
this cast and
they had a couple of teachers man they
had one name is Barnes and she was
ice-cold boy but I don't try to warm her
heart the long way you know and then
they had a couple of other teachers I
think one of them miss breast her son I
think her name was Josh yeah
stop lying stop lying you made that uh
you made that up
it's like Usain Bolt yeah I know right
just appropriate I don't know if that's
an odd amount of peer not this breast
Orson was dude I couldn't even I never
saw her head or her stomach relax all
you saw all I ever saw was her breast
bra and it was a nice line I don't
remember it was just this big huge chunk
of warmth that would just be in front of
your face dude great way to describe it
was just and I think she get in there Oh
nest you just want to blouse up you know
it was I mean she I think she was in a
blouse or a [ __ ] tourniquet I don't
even know what she was in there any kid
that wasn't you'd be on the other truck
food yeah not a tourniquet man then oh
and it just looked like one big wide tit
you know and it just was
oh she wanted it I don't know if she did
or not but when I would get closer
there's so much heat coming out of it
that I couldn't even barely [ __ ] see
it my eyes would fog up and I would
think I had glasses all about it didn't
even have glasses on dude my [ __ ]
eyes would fog up she lens you bro
that's how bad her titties were man he
had lenses without Wow your retinas with
foie gras dude yeah my retinas had fog
great we worked the fifth I don't
remember I don't remember learning after
that no you single or double digits oh I
was saying oh no I was double digit okay
cuz I remember all the blood were
running my bod like the my lower
extremities and I would faint dude cuz I
had this thing when I was young if you
that my blood would go not only to my
wiener but it would also go to the rest
of my extremities my legs yeah my lower
body yeah and so I had to wear these
compression pants you ever seen those
people warm yeah I see them uh
infomercial yeah I had to wear those in
middle school because my blood my blood
would fill up all of my legs whenever I
would get sexually aroused and I would
[ __ ] pass out so they could always
the worst part was
could tell when I was sexually aroused
did you be on the floor oh I just feel
like oh [ __ ] dude he was a wreck and
just me and my buddies playing hoops
Wow like that means what do you you
gotta be working with something you
might you gotta have a Duraflame I mean
you got got it yeah I got some width but
it's real the height that's questionable
no but you know they call the tunic and
you know it doesn't hit the back but the
sides get taking all the sides yeah I
mean tear up the wall but so that means
you were feeling up you know I mean oh
yeah okay I couldn't even bring you and
I'll just remember my eyes or just kind
of go empty and then I would go down but
how's your cap game you know what I mean
good cap on them oh oh
small penis head really big body oh okay
so it's like one of those trucks that
the cat the caboose gets wider when they
add extra wheels oh yeah what is that
those pickup trucks and then some a wide
yeah yeah just at the back yeah so
you're kind of like a stealth bomb
yeah okay I got my dick Scott's big hips
on the we are we're just who we are
that's what I like that um yeah messy
you yet so that's it whatever you want
see your aim is to shoot it you want to
shoot another special soon yeah I did my
first special and it was on confidential
and my second one was on Showtime and I
have to say I've never had anything I
think
air more than anything Showtime put it
on Showtime Showtime to the Showtime 3
then Showtime 3a then Showtime Spanish
and Showtime Redbox I mean it was on
like 17 showtimes good huh it was
awesome and I can't thank them enough
and it was like for two years straight
but I mean I take it like eight percent
of something yeah like I felt like it
wow you know it didn't help as much no
and now it's on the Spanish Network and
it's on a lot hmm I'm a priest a dad
Nouveau and so I don't know I don't know
who watches what so now I feel like I
get more hits off of podcasts and people
will quote stuff I did on a podcast yeah
and so now I just want to do one to just
do it because I have all this new stuff
and you know I don't even you know I
just want to make it and just get it on
the platform yeah I don't even have to
they don't have to make it cuz you know
my thing my audience will find it yeah
you know it's just no I haven't you used
to have one job two jobs you know I
don't know now you do 15 jobs
everybody's Ryan Seacrest yeah it's
pretty wild
do you think it's because that the
networks and that the the production
companies don't do what they used to do
or do you think because it does seem
like a transition of responsibility a
little bit or is that just or is there
just so many people in the game now it's
it's it's so much coming at us every
second like if you do I do this podcast
at 2 o'clock you know if I don't do
another one of 4 I'm out of the business
yeah I mean it's like it used to be like
this like you do things and you go to
the next level you do stand-up comedy
blow up in that then you do TV you blow
up in that and then you do movies and
you blow up in that and then you kind of
stay there now you do everything because
everything feeds everything and there's
so much content that you can have
different avenues that are very
successful yeah and I just think that
also just is so much stuff that you have
to just be out there yeah am I wrong I
mean yeah it's weird you got to stay
yeah it's like you have to stay out
there to advertise and it's not so much
doing it as much as just being relevant
like I want to say you got to be good
which you do but I almost feel like
being out there is the new talent mmm in
a way that makes that sound yeah it
definitely seems interesting I you know
I never thought about like that think
about it yeah I mean yeah it's like you
want to be out there but if you want it
but if you're but like because some
people that I love I haven't seen in a
while and it's like is the town
forgetting about them yeah but it's like
you see some of these guys that are
doing everything I mean the rock is
arguably the biggest movie star in the
world you grew it he just got 21 million
dollars which is the toppest I've ever
heard of upfront and then a million
dollars to promote the movie on his
social media that's 22 million jeez
that's the biggest I've ever heard and
he has a YouTube channel yeah that he
actively works on yeah
that's incredible that he doesn't have
to do that he knows that he's just gonna
hit every corner I mean that is
incredible he's gonna do it all he's I
believe he's the mass do you well I mean
it's so hard for also anyone especially
I feel like more and more these days to
stay you can't really stay at the height
of comedy like you used to be able to it
doesn't seem like you know and I almost
think in a strange way that like Dane
Cook was the last guy I feel like that
because he he really hit whatever if you
want to say about Dane you know and I
think he's okay he's kind of you know
he's not really engaged with me much he
always just seems like he does his own
thing but but he hit like Steve Martin
levels of popularity oh yeah
and then you can icon right in a con he
was an icon and you can't stay there
really there's no like very few
comedians have stayed at a level that's
I mean maybe Chappelle Chris Rock mm-hmm
they're still there yeah like this but
there's so few mm-hmm there's so few I
mean even I mean bilborough's like he's
not a celebrity cuz I think he chooses
not to be I think he likes being I mean
he's a he's the best comedian I think to
me I agree but um but there's only it's
hard to it's almost an impossible level
to maintain mm-hmm
you know I think you hit you know I've
never hit those heights you know I've
done well but it's like you hit those
heights I think it is it's like yeah man
you have it is hard to to stay there and
I do you think that you have something
to do with that because you've had some
good heights in your career you know
like I mean you've been a movie star
mm-hmm do you feel like and I've taken
people down off their highs know that
you um but do you feel like when you're
at that level is there Diouf is there
something tangible that you feel like
okay I can maintain this or do you still
feel like things are kind of up in the
air it's it's it's moves man it's really
moves it's like it's chess right you
like you know get apart
and you another part and you know the
part and one part feeds another part and
it's literally like ooh what about this
guy I just saw him in this Steven this
demon is right so it's like momentum
inertia and then you start moving up and
then you get a leading part and then if
that works then you get another leading
part it was that scary when you started
to get those was that scary no man I
always wanted that that was exciting
yeah what and it's basically like you
feel I'll tell you this you feel that
it's it will last forever yeah you
definitely feel like I felt like that
yeah cuz stuff was coming so easy to me
and I mean it doesn't mean I don't work
hard no I mean I did a lot of stuff but
I mean once I was on that grind
I'm doing every talk show I'm taking
every studio pitch meeting I'm getting
you know I'm selling every script and it
was like that but then once you know
something doesn't work or it's like if
something doesn't work critically but it
works commercially you're good
mmm reluctantly good right say like all
right we got to deal with them cuz we
can't turn down money it is against
Hollywood's you know DNA to turn down
money right you know that and its
business yes but if something critically
doesn't work box office but it's a
critic darling you're all so good mmm so
something doesn't work critically and
doesn't work commercially and then you
know that turnover rate cuz you think
about it people gotta make the lights
they got keep the lights on so it's like
boom you're not working it's yeah let's
go to the next let's go to next and then
of someone else cuz there's always
somebody right there in that dugout yeah
and bam if they hug it step in they get
a hit boom it's on and then you gotta
kind of you know you go down the farm
leagues yeah yeah I mean I've been in
the ecuador leagues I've been doing time
in Turkey but you know I'm slowly I'm
coming back yeah and I'm not like a
double-a ball right yeah you know
triple-a I'm a plane footer like that
you know the Tampa Bay you know
Grizzlies I'm gonna do
did you get like all daddies oh yeah you
know I think it Louisiana yeah Louisiana
what do we have we have the New Orleans
has the baby cake baby cakes I'm like
that team yeah and they're a good team
mhm
there's some good fans for they got
Wednesday night they got there's a free
Frank Frank night free Frank night do
you like do what about like ego and
stuff will you at that level do you
notice your ego changes like I think
egos such this strange thing it's like
out of our control sometimes almost did
you notice yourself get an ego or do you
always feel like kind of the same or did
you like what was that some of that like
not in a bad way and not judging you I
think whatever you want yeah so I asked
what you want and I'm gonna answer it
was my ego like yeah no I'm not dude I
love you man I think it the first thing
that came to my mind when you said that
was I was right I was right like because
you struggle you know you try to come up
and you're coming up and you're like
yeah I'm on the right path yeah I'm
supposed to do how I can see that yeah
this is working um I mean I will tell
you this I don't I mean I guess he had
my ego is large
I haven't eaten so much humble pie I was
talking to Bobby Lee about this and now
I'm like I want to sound I mean I still
gotta go but I really can't
it's I've been checked yeah and
chin-checked yeah I mean and it's really
good for me because now I feel like boom
I'm not gonna say there's people take it
the wrong way but I like hit my bottom
yeah you know I mean and there's nothing
you can do a growth I've seen so much
and seen so little yeah and so I did the
only thing I can think of the only what
you're saying there is patience at times
because doing so much you're doing a
movie you're doing a TV show you're
playing you know 3,000 people out of
college and you're like oh I gotta go I
gotta go and you're you know flying on a
private jet and your life so it's like
you doing stuff yeah and you and you're
seeing it around and you're just like
let's go let's go let's go so sometimes
you can be hurt you can be short and
people get butthurt and then but I've
always made sure hey I'm sorry Baba bah
yeah um but I've always I think I've
maintained simple
but definitely your ego Hollywood
doesn't make you more it just exposes
who you are hmm and generally I'm a I'm
a good guy but I definitely have you
know crazy moments yeah definitely
living and and I do think though that
you have creativity though I don't care
this is what annoys me but people get
the role is difficult and I think
there's times I've had some creative
fights with people and other times it's
consequently but it's creative man yeah
that this is the sandbox and that's what
I don't like about our business now
people ratting out what's going on and
settle this person did this this person
did that there's the difference between
somebody being really difficult for
unnecessary reasons and people that are
trying to create something great yeah
and when that happens ah you know I mean
cuz we're not there to make friends
we're there to make something great and
yeah we haven't become friends after it
god bless it that's what I feel and
there's people like that but some people
get difficult but then there's other
people that are difficult that super it
was successful they don't get difficult
because they're successful yeah like
Picasa or vengo vengo the difficult is
[ __ ] do cut off his own [ __ ] ear
yeah but he also did great work
Picasso [ __ ] the 20 year old had a
baby was 91 yeah I mean good see this is
a deeper conversation I don't wanna go
off the rails down a rabbit no but it's
like people want everybody has a choice
no you don't everybody's special no
you're not
yeah okay people like people want
everybody to be all clean and normal
everybody well behaved now
Kurt Cobain [ __ ] blew his brains out
when he's 24 but guess what
you got bleach here you got in utero
okay Sid Vicious [ __ ] gave you the
Sex Pistols he wasn't great at taxes
yeah you know and I'm saying Amy
Winehouse she died at 27 yeah but you
got rehab you've got just like so
everybody wants everything to be perfect
hear me amazing artist if they're a
well-put-together person - god bless it
the ones I know most of them and I love
art it's not the way it happened and
that's who they are
but guess what you get a [ __ ]
painting yeah you get just the ten of us
remember that show yo yeah that was a
good one remember that TV show who was
that dude at in daughters bro
but I don't just saying yeah you get
William Wallace like sure Mel Gibson
might be he might have some [ __ ]
racial issues right or some you know
judicial issues not just religious
issues but you get [ __ ] William
Wallace yeah but he's good on horseback
you know I'm saying I know but you know
he it's like I'm not judging I'm not
justifying it but I am I I don't know
you tell me no look every it's you
here's what you want every people punch
me in the face but they're amazing at it
amazing comedian or a singer go for it
like Joan Rivers said she didn't like
Rodney Dangerfield I read something but
she would never miss his set mmm that's
how I am man somebody can hate me call
me names spit my eyeball if they're
great at what they do I'll still be
there yeah cuz you know right I separate
that [ __ ] you know I have to feel like
you've always been one of the nicer
people that I've ever met man thank you
for sure everybody says that I feel like
really yeah and you're so funny
um thank you yeah I just love seeing you
like you know just from my little
perspective just dig into it like I'm
like damn this dude's coming back you
know we're not coming back but he's you
know he's fighting back but you're not
wrong and I feel like a lot of people
think I'm gonna I don't know if they do
like do people think I'm an actor doing
comedy cuz I am an actor but I got
famous right as an actor and you were
young but I did start as a comedian yeah
Chris Spencer's did something that he
said something he's so funny come once
ago he's like yeah man it's like it
happened quick for you is like I think
you did eight sets which is too late' I
was doing a lot of open mic right and
then like my club back then you know I
would do the store but only like in the
potluck yeah you know what hang out
there in the back you know that one
training and yeah oh you're always
trying to get on and but the improv
would have showcased nights and the
factory was and I'm telling once I
waited in line like 12 times in the
factory and then Jamie Mossad like
bodied na Mario in and my first showcase
like I did get a commercial agent Wow so
I was lucky and then The Improv my third
like showcase I did like get an agent so
getting on these little showcases that
hell it yeah so I didn't really work and
then once I got a fast-rising me did but
now it's on open mics for a long time
in the clubs I didn't really get in but
then once I started getting successful
then I was able to do that more but then
I went right to colleges yeah so I
literally started like 30 minutes in
colleges I had to work on that and then
like guys like saggy let me open for him
and Craig shoemaker and you know um Rick
Overton and they taught me a lot yeah oh
geez but but I did start at the comic
and then I just got successful but now I
feel like you know there's a oh this guy
is doing that used to be well you're an
actor doing economy but then it went but
now as everybody is trying it you know
just yeah good man you express yourself
yeah everybody's trying to make think
yeah I think the ones that stick with it
you are the ones that are you know I can
do it stay in it yeah my mind okay just
like anything I go on the road and like
thanks to Bobby Lee and saying you gotta
like just do town and town is hotter
than it's ever been that I know mhm I
think for three years I mean the clubs
are booming and every star you see doing
ten minutes and I feel that it's good
for me and I just makes me better on the
road but I did realize this weekend I
was doing killer shows sold out Wow
in Tacoma which was bomb it's awesome up
there it's amazing
did you go to Spokane as well oh yeah
yeah dad the best-run clubs man and they
really are yeah I do a great job up
there they keep that drawer those things
a pac-man little now and laters those
big Tootsie's mmm but as much as I was
having great time there I still was like
I got to get back to town yeah because I
gotta work I gotta be in the mix right
and that's what I learned
dude Harry Basel he opened up for Rodney
Dangerfield for a long time and he told
me one time he goes look man
he said the road will always be there he
goes get out there and make your Brent
where you got to make it'll make you a
little money here and there he goes but
if you want to be in it you got to be in
it
yeah and I think there's still some
truth to that you know it's like you
have a set you just don't know who's
gonna be in there sometimes I know you
just don't know I mean I walked in the
comedy store one night in and Jim Carrey
was sitting there watching the comedians
who were going up and that's how he cast
the show uh dying up here yeah
and I performed and I was nervous as
[ __ ] dude and it wasn't for them and
that's you know and that was that not
dejected I felt way did you know he was
there yeah so it was a special night
yeah I would hole up in the parking lot
guys like Jim's here
what's it packed and like a gym ooh and
he's like Jim Carrey and like will
[ __ ] say Jim Carrey yeah I know are
you tight with Jim we've never seen
before it's like somebody did that to me
in the day well she's like you know
Rhonda and I'm like who's Ron it's like
my knees I don't know [ __ ] [ __ ]
give up yeah okay so he's like Jesus and
I'm like I know Jesus Christ like you
know the valley
yeah yeah so wait so but yeah it's like
you never get it you don't know so you
want to be in town that's I mean I get
nervous all the time and I've to leave
town I'm like [ __ ] what if I miss that
set that's you know I guess maybe you do
think somebody could still see you on
stage and things could change for you
dude [ __ ] it for me [ __ ] I mean Quinn
Tarantino's at the store yeah I mean
sure one of the greatest movies about to
make you know so I agree with you but
it's and it's also becoming so much like
you know improv going up late you know
yeah you get to work you don't get to do
more than you know you're 15 maybe to 30
yeah lab or you know or yeah it's just
it feels like comedy where it is where
it's like I love going up 12:31 yeah you
know and just working it jazz in it yeah
you can have a little more free time
mm-hmm
man Wow I love seeing at the close man
and I appreciate you're always you
always supportive and say nice things
man and I just really appreciate that
well I appreciate you man yeah I think
people appreciate that about you man
I've devised it's it's a beautiful time
and I just want to do you know I want to
respect our and just it's it's awesome I
mean for people out there watching and
listening it's like I don't know I
probably equate it to Seattle 92 yeah I
mean are they gonna say cialis bro the
allottee startup Network I did early see
Alice was very [ __ ] yeah god I'm glad
they've remixed it Yeah right too strong
it was strong yeah but is that where you
were Seattle 92 no I'm staying all over
grunge bands man yeah you walk here
housing changes here Nirvana was here
Eddie Vedder's over there
shitty was silverchair I think did a bit
I know their Australian yeah but they
stopped by yeah right that's on Anna who
else Alien Ant Farm alien and much about
let's you go to local coffee shop you
never Iser
polarizer thing so I just lucky that you
know I do that's one thing where did you
get grateful you get just to go on these
stages
you seem grateful were you super
grateful but was there a period where
you weren't was there a period where you
got in the dumps or anything no I was
just like [ __ ] yeah of course I'm gonna
be on this stage looking at me yeah you
know what I mean yeah like if you're in
a movie or in a TV show it's like yeah
I'll come down and it's like whoa and
then you know somebody kicking the dick
and then you're doing you know half an
hour and a bowling alley in Toledo which
I'd done yeah you know and people get
pissed off and [ __ ] throw a chair or
somebody in the audience and you're like
whoa wait a minute
I gotta readjust I'm not exactly where I
thought I was so then you see you know
you go back and you're like oh I'm so
happy to be where I am yeah because in
here yeah I'm not it's it's it
everything has time you know where clubs
are hot and they're cold and artists are
hot and cold I mean cuz all you know
clubs get hot cold oh yeah and now it's
just everything is gelling in this but
podcast is so hot Netflix is so hot
dreaming is so hot more comedians are
great and it's just it's possible yeah
I'm just lucky to be in the stream yeah
man that's what it is now
and there's a great [ __ ] I don't wanna
go to down the rabbit hole but I'm
there's a great talk you know what the
sharing economy is right so the sharing
economy is where we were it's basically
what's going on right now it's uber it's
you know Airbnb ok it's like owning is
is out ya know millenials are gonna
disrupt credit cards and disrupting
Captain Crunch you need all the stuff
that millennial did yeah he's a first
mate now I heard yeah yeah string cheese
and not eating string cheese and they're
[ __ ] it up right because they don't
want to have any debt they want to be
cash boom post me it's buh-buh-bah venmo
so you share so there's this video damn
I wish I could find it I'll talk to you
but it talks about to Jenna
and the old generation was like whose
get what you could write and kinda like
I don't want to say step on your fellow
man but yo get yours limited resources
get this hat get four hats yeah get nine
hats you got one head you need nine hats
yeah and it's out of that recession era
right and then my generation is like
gets that but it's also half I got my
first computer like 23 and I'm 47 so
it's like half my life right so now half
of me is like understands the tech and
so I might get that but also like you
share the old generation the new
generation is all like yo a little bit
here a little bit there so if you notice
it's the sense of community to me is
bigger than it's ever been in terms of
things I see I see more artists
collaborating in a music right I see
kamini more yes and you look at look at
the Avengers every one of those people
would are movie stars in their own right
but the 12 people are starring in the
movie together yeah
and that's that model of Marvel is a
model for I think art and Hollywood
right is that yeah it's like it look
less per - together instead of just Rod
one yeah and it's been it's beautiful
and I'm in the middle now but I'm really
going to this generation of like yo man
jump on yeah it's not you know the Jamie
Kennedy Train
right it's you know it's the Polar
Express yeah and we're all [ __ ] chilly
bear hang on yeah yeah I mean yeah it'll
go to this car yeah yo you got cut out
that one part did you I'm not sure which
part is talking about but I thought it's
all fair game yeah what is how say what
time we at Nick oh we're at 3:30 exactly
Oh an Instagram question yeah yeah let's
take a couple Instagram questions man uh
so you mentioned earlier Eddie Murphy
was one of your heroes yeah someone
asked about working in Bowfinger with
him and Steve Martin what was that like
who was funniest out of two
oh come on who the file okay well how
about this
who was funniest onset that's a totally
different thing oh that's from
infinitely interesting okay add so first
of all you take like icon icon I mean
right he's talking about you know the
highs I mean this is Steve Martin is the
first arena comedian Eddie was a second
yeah dice was the third and Dane was
like fifth yeah you know so it's
incredible here's what's great about it
uh they're both do what they do in front
of the camera amazingly well and
hilarious and off camera
chill mmm and that's I totally get it I
got it then but I really get it now who
had more do you think they had more like
who you think got more hot chick she
think out of those two I think I mean
Steve Martin said this great quote to me
once and you know he said that at the
height of his fame he was a rock star
without the girls hmm cuz I think he was
so big when he meant by that and so many
people are throwing themselves at him
and women and he just would go to his
hotel room because it was mania I
couldn't even get an erection of a
family if you know somebody's banging on
the door while you're trying to I could
you know saying that would be the worst
my worst nightmare I think that people
chasing me to [ __ ] yeah I think that a
noted well but I think that I don't
really ask Eddie but I really I Stevie
did but he told me that I just remember
that was amazing he was so huge that he
had to be isolated yeah which is
incredible which is what I'm talking
about how it's changed yes he couldn't
walk down sunset yeah you know what I'm
saying is that because less avenues one
thing gets it back it's like we're all
going for oil you strike well now now
you gotta have dinosaur bones you gotta
have time you gotta have soil yeah you
gotta have piping and then you get oil
solar but wait yeah you gotta have all
of that but you hit one it's a big spout
but now I feel like people are hitting
and there's some good sized spouts but
there's little or spouse yeah
ETA's xylophone and pie pipeline yeah
it's dice first yeah dice first paul
reiser yeah dice first by paul reiser
sounds like a ball right admit wasn't he
in my to my two dads my two dads and
that was good dude I was eight he's one
of the greatest and also one of the only
that would be like a me too yeah warning
video now man living with a girl and one
of them's allegedly related to her or
something yeah she had a young boy
friends over yeah I was a tricky deal um
let's take another one Nick what do we
got
alright @j hustle 37 he wants to know
some basketball takes and you who's to
go kobe MJ or LeBron yeah yeah dude
didn't you play in like a celebrity
all-star game no cuz I remember watching
that on television
nah yeah I was not bad from the three
yeah a couple of garbage points who was
the MVP that game do you remember I was
before heart heart was getting a lot it
was recognized up like for yeah but
people are holding him up by the who
wasn't shaq holding him up yeah he got
help and then I think beaver got one I
think this was around oh seven I want
maybe Marc Blucas Marc Blucas look him
up he's a legit baller he's an actor but
he's don't wait for us who's the better
I mean boys a quote dude that's the
hardest question in the world but to me
there's only one Jordan yeah 100% here's
why
I don't I hope you know I don't wanna
piss people off or whatever yes someone
is if they don't agree that is me enough
to get pissed and I can pull the truck
over don't pull your truck oh yeah but
last night LeBron he got beat he did
everything in his power here's why I
think LeBron is just a little off and
he's an amazing superhuman yeah he's
good he lost last night his team lost
and he goes it's not gonna [ __ ] my life
you know I'm gonna go home we're gonna
figure out the next games not gonna
affect my life no that's what I don't
want to see I wanna see
damn it yeah he's [ __ ] I dropped 40
[ __ ] two points these guys I [ __ ]
I'm on the weak side I'm on the left
side these guys are good man I'm so
[ __ ]
pissed yeah I gotta go in there and I
gotta just jam on [ __ ] yeah
that's what I want to see I wish he did
that yeah
and that's the noise but that's but MJ
that's the one thing for me he will eat
your aorta brah
yeah I heard that [ __ ] didn't
like to lose in penny tossing like he
didn't you know you know twizzler he you
you need a quick I mean he would bet
this I heard he got a house here yeah he
will eat your soul and that's why he's
the best ever because he refuses to lose
it yeah had to me is the most exciting
yeah I agree I think his mindset was
just different I think it was a
different time
I think LeBron is just one of those guys
he would be great at any sport he's a
big yeah he you know he'd be great at
the violin if he did it he's just one of
those people that could be good at
almost anything he chose basketball yeah
he's a savant but Jordan I think yeah I
think it was basketball only I mean he
was shitty at baseball you know play for
the White Sox people try to act like you
know he was he wasn't any good yeah he's
[ __ ] bad actually he was yeah yeah
maybe probably [ __ ] he owned the team
for three years he got it he got every
head bat one game to let him pitch to
himself both he the think like that well
let him watch it that he's watching
we're doing good
Jamie Kennedy where can people see you
at coming up this weekend right now okay
whatever it is I'm at Rochester at the
Carlson you are yeah I can go out and
look on there you want to look on his
site and just love these dates Nick so
we'll have them and then next weekend
I'm at the rec room and Huntington Beach
then and then like in the early June in
Ontario improv nice you want to get
those we'll put those dates to UM right
my on the screen yeah right below in the
link and we'll put the dates up on the
screen - dude I appreciate you so that
people will know them if you haven't
seen Jamie in a while man go check them
out if you have seen when while go check
them out again dude your IMDB so long
it's crazy bro like you could almost put
two words together and you were [ __ ]
in it bro slacker cats
you don't say if I can't put in mas
yeah it's a hot day time jugglers like
you are in every king of the
millionaires - Bentley bottom Gang Gang
[Laughter]
you're in sugar walkers no slacker catch
it'll work yes good a work man well so
many cats are lazy
we was seven and out I watch I think I
watched more will you that was around
Tootsie time me a Mikey Rush boy all
right
Oh [ __ ] slick JA Raj did I'd love to
see him and you're a little priest go
toe to toe if I can also mouth dude how
is mouth stuffing online not a thing
let's make it yeah yo Lenny was not even
Millennials now no just people that are
home a lot there's the new generation
I'm I think um X and there's what I
thought might be X job I think you're
wild y then and then there's Millennials
Millennials and now the new one whatever
that is under Millennials yeah you know
that eating ramen out of toilet are they
really yeah honey and the challenge with
the type on all that stuff it's like the
challenge is can you do but they're
eating ramen cooking it mm-hmm
and eating out what that hot batch boy
yeah get what you want I remember that a
couple brothers my neighborhood always
cook and of outside of our apartment
complex right and so I go out there dog
meat and so I'd go out there and uh and
for years he's used you like he wants
some dove no I said no yeah and then
finally I had some and that [ __ ] was
soft it was it was me thinking close my
eyes and think about what it tasted like
it was overcooked they've they bred it
no they didn't bred it was straight Duff
blackened of
yes blackened of boy double blacken
because he's a couple brothers service
yeah but it was a I think it was kind of
Jamaican I think honestly you know is
Jamaican like jerk dove
it was jerk does I want to believe that
do you better believe yeah yes train
Orleans
I'm Covington Lousiana man no but people
whoíve or thwart Oh New Orleans Italy
whatever bro you know I'm saying New
Orleans a great place and ie what and
I'm gonna make a chart to crime and food
how they merged better crime better food
Baltimore [ __ ] crabs and cutthroat
son you know I'm saying New Orleans or
oysters and [ __ ] body slugs you know
catch a dozen of the [ __ ] tongue and
[ __ ] two to the chest baby yeah
that's true yeah that's true
better food better better food comes
with murder yeah cuz they cook like it
might be your last meal and no offense
to the cops cuz they've been good to me
down there but they only move on you
know if they figure out what's in it for
them oh yeah they got some shaky cops
down there for a em some of those cops
like what's in it for me yelling that
cop was like that bean yeah you know
that's you know they've got a paying
cash what's it called that Cafe Du Monde
come on I got it that one bite in that's
the thing to run right Oh a lot of
counsel hide a gun in a couple of pin
yes just be eatin for everybody's at the
dull I'm going down there no one are you
yeah I think I'm shooting something I
can't say yeah nyeeehhh
and the thing is you pay cash yeah the
waiters so when you go to do mines open
all night yeah that what you want my
yeah you pay cash dude yes to the
waiters yeah because the waiters got pay
cash to the owners there's two owners so
people don't know all right there's two
guys I own this joint and they're scared
of each other [ __ ] each other so they
each have their own cash register so
they [ __ ] hit eat way to go go go get
them right they take cash and then go
that guy order doughnut you only three
[ __ ] bucks the waiters got a peso is
the the waiters don't collect they
[ __ ] that's America dude that's [ __ ]
beignet
no beignet fashioned yay
yeah Jamie thanks so much me you gotta
come back you got to start your own cast
man I think people would love listening
to you I would love to man listen I
would love it I'm not gonna use this -
if you need to every now and then you
know I'm cuckoo you need to take him you
know to get that kick off but I think
you mean if you know just saying all
right like - my god I see people should
have hit me up and cuz and if they like
me all of I think people would huh be
interesting do a 12-episode want to see
how you feel about yeah but I want to
like you know I want to talk different
than what I am now I'm just sitting on
your front porch wondering how could I
be so far from my home and my mom is
somewhere else but when I found it our
patch up where it's been grown now I'm
just floating on the breeze and I feel
up full and like these leaves I must be
cornerstone
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of mind
[Music]